Joe why the [ __ ] would you take the
White House correspondence dinner I
think that sounds like so much pressure
and then it seems like afterwards it's a
no-win situation everybody just
criticizes you anyway I'm I'm preparing
for that uh I it's a weird because I
it's like when they asked all I thought
was well I can't not say no to that it
could seemed like exactly and I was just
on Letterman yesterday and he's like I
don't think that would be a good idea
for me to do that no but I bet you
because they want you to goof on you
know the whole Washington scene they
want you to even goof a little bit be
playful with the president but you can
only go so far like do they they thought
Colbert went too far they did it yeah
because that was during the bush era
right and he well he did what he does
which so well right playing that
character and it did not if you watch
the speech it's brilliant but it did not
and at the time people were like what
are you doing you're making fun of the
president so has anybody vetted you has
anyone said look man we don't know about
you or or what are you going to be doing
no they not yet they all they said the
only thing note I was like can you just
make sure you make fun of that like
don't just make fun of the president I'm
like well of course I'm not yeah have
you written all your jokes I mean have
you have you got all your materials set
for what you're going to do I've never
generated more material in my life and
how many guys will write this thing for
you I brought the two guys that are
mainly writing it they're they're here
with me because they're traveling with
me and what are their credentials like
how do you choose them to write your
jokes they worked for E so well what
else can you have are they on Talk Soup
they were they very long ago they were
on the on the suit but then they have
written almost every appearance as far
as uh just jokes they've written
everywhere and what do you do do you pay
them or there's the the the the yeah you
have to pay them not I'm paying them I'm
paying other writers I'm paying for my
family to fly out I have never spent
more how much is costing you I think
about and Kimmel said you're going to
spend so much money you won't believe it
I think at this point I'm up to about
forty thousand dollars do they pay you
and at all they do pay oh they do it's
not a big check it's a stipend yes did
Jimmy give you Jimmy Kimmel give you any
advice on doing this what was his advice
he said he if he said he could go back
and do it again he would cut out about
30 of his jokes oh really not they were
all very great I mean they're great
jokes but he said uh just brevity just
keep it short keep it sweet and short
and it seems to me most guys go on and
on and on for like a half hours a lot of
people go if you but if the lat like so
I I this is how much I've studied Seth
Meyers went like 15 minutes oh he did uh
Conan did like 17 minutes right and then
Kimmel did barely 20 but then other guys
they've gone longer and the thing is
this is the last I'm the last person up
and they've all been sitting for three
hours and I'm the last thing keeping
them from going out to all the parts
this is the worst [ __ ] thing but
they're waiting for you because you're
going to give some sarcastic yeah
everyone wants you to be like the badass
and then when you're the badass everyone
will criticize you yeah this is no win
[ __ ] John there's gonna be a lot of
[Music]
and it's something that's evaluated that
you get a grade yeah yeah the next day
yeah the newspapers grade you it's like
a whole thing and it seems to me Nobody
Does it two or three years in a row do
they no no is it that they don't invite
people back to do it again or is it
because everybody just gets so
criticized that they don't even want to
come back I think it's I think it's uh
they give someone else a shot Conan's
done it twice he did it early on in his
career I think so they brought a couple
people I think Bob Hope probably did it
a few times but now when guys write all
this material for you and you do it now
now have you timed it out how long
you're going to actually go for we we've
timed it but we have to cut we've all we
agree we have to cut it about in half
how long are you right now uh we're
about 25 minutes oh that's too long
accordingly the Jimmy Kimmel philosophy
is cut cut cut cut and you have to go so
you have to talk slow because in that
situation you wanna you know you get
excited and you're it's you're gonna
just like being in a race where you all
of a sudden you're it's almost like
almost like a reading contest you know
because you're sitting there reading
jokes to people essentially yeah but you
got to have a good delivery and you're
right you have to go slow because you
probably your Tendencies I just want to
get this the [ __ ] over yeah right and
you've got 4 000 people in that room and
you've got all these there's dishes
clanking people getting up to go to the
bathroom and you know after a three-hour
evening it's very hard to be funny I
mean there's just so much that can go
wrong I don't mean to keep throwing you
know no I'll be but I'll be on the fire
but I'll be getting ready like I'm in a
rocket launch are you gonna drink you
know because you don't think about all
of that if I got up there Tipsy have a
few shots
hey everybody uh I can't remember what I
was gonna say did you write anything so
far that you considered too mean and you
threw it right up but it was a killer
joke there are jokes that because that
one of the things everyone says is don't
go blue because that you'll lose them
because everybody is a very I mean even
the Democrats will be conservative when
it comes back they don't want to be seen
laughing when you say work blue like you
won't say ass you'll say Kimmel did say
[ __ ] right and there was a big ooh
but I think he knew he knew he was
getting a good reaction but even if you
get ooze that's a reaction better than
silence and staring now in retrospect
that you've put in this couple of months
planning for this are you kind of like
you know [ __ ] I shouldn't have done this
do you have any regrets saying yes no
I'm I really am happy but the size the
glass of wine that I'm gonna have
afterwards